moi je vous dis ce soir j'ai décidé
qu'on se dise tourné dans une ambiance
vacances on oublie tout et sachez que
tout ce qui se dira sur ce plateau
restera sur ses platines et elle elle
parce que vous la voyez comme ça mais
chasse est une personne qui est au bout
du rouleau en a marre qui a envie de
dire ce soir ni qu'on me dit la vérité
booba nico moque voilà oui alors lui il
en dépression mais total vous dites tout
quand même à oui je vous dit tout il
raconte mal avec kelly on disait le
temps c'est fou on n'a pas fait l'amour
de cui à bout deux bébés bas mais pas en
temps voulu de on n'a pas faire ou tu
veux vraiment que je dise aux gens ce
que tu m'as envoyé hier soir
alors il ajouté ils étaient les invités
qui vont décider françois xavier
demaison c'est comme ça que vous voulez
savoir ce qu'il en voyait qu'élire
c'était vraiment moi j'aimerais beaucoup
voilà merci ou alors si je vous dis ils
vous montrez pas la photo je peux dire
parce que je n'ai face et à tulle est
passé respectivement
alors oui j'aimerais que ce qu elle y
dévoile pas de lui envoyer un sms dit la
vérité
alors j'ai posé une question simple je
vais te dire c'est tout simple nike a
juste posé la question qui tue préfère
entre matthieu delormeau
c'est simple tu vas te fâche avec un des
deux hommes avaient quitté la même
question en oubliant de salaire pas et
donc ne dis la vérité maintenant y'a pas
besoin de choisir entre vous deux pour
montrer ses mains en mains ouais ouais
et un moment de nommer des juges il est
déjà en train de scander les noms je me
dis [ __ ] je pense que tu as beaucoup
de qualités mais je pense que tu es un
petit sexe
j'ai jamais dit ça j'ai vu venir dit
elle ne faisait pas de jure sur ta vie
c'est là que j'ai en fait face et la
photo je sans toi moi je te l'envoie
photo pb oui parce que
[Rires]
c'est vraiment bien je vous dise toi
gentil puis les faces c'est juste une
photo mh je tiens à donner ma version la
vente écoles oui assez bon je vous
explique à mathieu m'inviter à temps
mais en deux minutes deux minutes la
firme ne s'est pas retourné beale 9e
fois faire ici faute certes n'a pas
bombardé logiciel merci sophie pic à
l'ex-régie en égrenant dont mathieu m'a
invité à dîner une énième fois
du coup je lui dis avec grand pesio on
va aller dîner ya pas de soucis et à un
moment donné je vais dit salut petite
boum
non c'est mignon ça c'est fait vous
connais bien ses toiles à aucun moment
je lui ai dit qu'elle est la taille de
ton sexe et donc il m'a dit jure la vie
de ta mère que je t'envoie mon sexe et
rien à personne à la faute alors
attendez pas à ce que moi j'ai bien
envie de rire les oiseaux
donc là vous êtes quand même là et tu
dis je te jure sur la vie de ma mère je
ne parlerai jamais de facebook ouais
conversation et la mi-journée ni entrer
ni un truc de wim envoie une photo
ouais et ses routes dink est vrai pas
lasser avec la main tu vois mal avec des
poils blonds ou non blancs bah oui alors
que je te dise départ ou bien si c'est
blanc bonnet on va voir maintenant
c'était blanc léger alors tu l'as fait
passer pour de vrai alors y'a pas de
bouillon n'y a plus rien c'est bon on a
pas de est-ce que c'est la vraie
histoire la vraie histoire et je jure
qu'elle a eu la vraie photo c'est pour
ça que ça alors là vraiment dire c'est
nous est arrivé la même chose à kelly et
moi et la pauvre elle a été obligé
d'installer chez elle un rétroprojecteur
[Applaudissements]